well from doggy porn to regular porn
we're go we're jumping back when we're
gonna talk well you know what watch the
clip and I will go ladies there is a
crisis looming in the church it has been
called the new bubonic plague as
addictive as crack cocaine Satan is
silently attacking the minds of
Christian men with a weapon which
threatens husbands dads fiancees and
even church leaders that weapon is
pornography pornography pornography
pornography pornography pornography worn
pornography pornography is easily
available affordable much of it is free
anonymous nobody has to know
there's almost a 100 percent chance that
your son will be exposed to some type of
pornography their cellphone can be a
tool used by Satan to gain a stronghold
into your child's mind I believe as many
as 80% of men in the church are
struggling with some level of viewing
pornography 40% of those responding
struggle with pornography 30% of pastors
had viewed pornography as a pastor I
have seen firsthand pornography's
devastating effects on a man his
marriage his home his job and his
leadership within the church the concept
I want you to take out of this video is
what happens to you when you get into
porn zone once the climax is over
through masturbation are through acting
out sexually in other ways a man returns
to his senses if you will then he will
think what was I thinking why did I
throw away everything that is dear to me
for this if there is any pornography in
your home destroy it immediately you
need to destroy all your porn stash 'as
you may even need to destroy your
present computer that leaves no place
for
pornography I don't think I got the
point of that it was pornography I'm
literally speechless I've watched that
ten times and it gets crazier each time
first off I'm pretty sure it was an
advertisement before now it's free it's
anonymous okay all right I mean he threw
out some crazy at 80% of men are
struggling with porn 30% of pastors are
watching porn I think it's just 80% of
dudes watch poll watch porn okay so
there's a lot of different ways we can
go with this and I'm even gonna take the
high road and not even comment on that
man's precisely Ellen's cousin perhaps
or maybe he's gay let's all right but
let's take the high road and leave that
aside what I mean what do people fear
about porn what is it about watching
porn that people think it's going to
destroy the world to me I think it's
religious though it's only the religious
people that have a problem with it but I
think when you look at a little bit look
at the Catholic Church for example they
have a huge problem with priests
molesting young boys hey I think because
the problem is they haven't really
gotten with the 21st century and you
realize oh maybe a man and a woman
should be allowed to be married right so
maybe they wouldn't just be segregated
their whole lives and sexually
suppressed and think that the only warm
thing I'm gonna get is an altar boy at
the same time they tell you being gay is
bad so if you don't have to get married
it's a pretty great place to go if you
don't want to be with a woman and that
right so right you know and look it
really I mean where is this guy living
because porn is not just porn where you
find it on redtube for free on the
internet we're talking about you can
watch a 12 year old girl walking down
the street that's barely clothed and
that's pretty much what he's talking
about right so out of 10 people watching
just went to read to people about Jesus
you're not supposed to name the free
porn
I was researching yeah are you talking
about how they've all left the newer a
bad business model when you tell
somebody over and over and over again
not to do something it's like don't kids
like yeah his right shoulder think of a
purple elephant yeah what did you just
think of you know there's better ways to
do this you know and that's the thing
I'm not really I'm not
you know Christian I'm not really
religious whatever but um when you have
a frank conversation with somebody about
sexuality or about pornography it
doesn't sound like that right it doesn't
sound like well you're possessed by
Satan and it doesn't sound like that
sounds like okay right just know that
these are the pitfalls of being porn
ruined and this is what it can do to
your marriage and this is what can do to
your relationships and this is what it
can do to young minds who are like
sponges who don't understand what
intimacy is okay so I think I think
you're hitting it beyond on the head we
never have that discussion that we
always make it sound like it's crazy
religious people saying no porn or a
bunch of sex maniacs saying point point
but the truth is somewhere in the middle
which is yes you can what we've all
probably watched too much porn if I
could have some of that time back I
probably would have wrote more jokes I
could have right now
you know you mean like we all could so
but why why are we afraid of having like
an honest conversation they want you to
think that it's something dirty so oh my
god it's dirty and I'm gonna feel bad
after I do it or watch it or whatever I
mean I've looked at porn I've looked at
part of my husband I don't think it's
made me a bad person I'm not addicted to
it it's not like I look it up every
night it hasn't ruined our relationship
we've been together 10 years we're
having a child I think it's like
anything in life you try to learn like
you say you learn the pitfalls I mean
that's part of being a human being and
learning from your parents or learning
hopefully from your pastor that maybe
it's not that crazy about it but you go
look this can be bad this could be bad I
mean it's like smoking it's bad for your
health they can do this to you it can
give you lung cancer it can make you die
prematurely it can make you look 10
years older than you are and you know
some people are probably still gonna go
smoke a cigarette and then they're gonna
go you know it's probably not for me or
I realize how to do it in moderation or
maybe I'm not gonna do it at all but
like where
that people you know the last time I
looked porn didn't kill anybody I mean
you know what I'm saying it didn't
actually physically murder anybody
people aren't dying from it so I'm like
you know well that's the funny thing
he's saying how what a detriment it is
and as a Christian this is you be your
number one right take that and figure it
out for myself
right lazy pastoring because when you
put just the Satan stamp of approval on
it without explaining or anybody's gonna
want to go look at exactly and yeah but
is that part of the trick that they're
doing actually by saying it's so bad
they know that then you'll be redeemed
by the church so it's like this is their
little trick we're gonna tell you about
something we're gonna tell you how much
this is how much everybody loves it it's
awful come to us we'll say you really
are making me feel derp I want to go to
the is their calendar or time stamp
somewhere cuz I'm going to say something
I have never said and I never thought I
would say in a million years we should
take a page from the teachings of George
W Bush one show and say with the the
splinter in the eye with the log in the
guy's mouth or whatever that was that's
we have to remember like these it's all
hypocrisy when you're saying all or
nothing do this and you're good don't do
this in you're bad I promise you Ellen's
cousin or whoever that guy does not do
that because he's human and that's what
makes us human we don't we alter and
make music big grey areas no he just
needs to simmer down yeah by the way I
should say that I since I just fumbled
my way into the segment because I was so
shocked by it
that's a Florida pastor by the way and
he's starting something called a million
men and he wants a million men 1 million
men to swear off the porn so good luck
with that buddy ok
[Music]